so advice for someone who even let's say
they grew up in LA and they decide you
know what I think I might want to try my
hand at the entertainment industry maybe
they don't want to be in front of the
camera or I want to do something in
development whatever right they think
well I've been here so I know the ropes
I know how la works and any advice if
you were to kind of sit someone down
who's maybe just out of college sure and
a bright sort of rising star that gets a
lot of compliments and sometimes I
wonder if that works to the detriment
because then people get too confident
well it's always good to feel confident
in yourself
most people don't so you what I say it's
the same which is you know you fake it
till you make it if you're not confident
but you know how to talk about yourself
and you really have it down what you
want to say that helps to overcome
shyness what I would say to somebody who
was in even if you're in Los Angeles
unless you travel in that circle because
as I was saying I grew up in Los Angeles
but didn't know anybody in the business
I think there's four parts of success in
Hollywood one is having blazing hot
material whatever your material is you
may be a writer and then it's your
portfolio you may be a director and then
it's your films you may be a
cinematographer and it's what you have
on your reel and your films lazy not
material and then really smart self
marketing which is another way to say
knowing how to develop and project your
industry profile and another way to say
that which I hate because it's so it it
it sounds so businesslike but is your
brand knowing who you are how you're
going to sell yourself that's 2/3 is
having enough connections having a
community of mutually beneficial
relationships that will help you in your
career they'll help move you up they'll
help you throughout your career if you
help them it's a it's a
it takes a perfect storm to get anything
enough people calling on your behalf
enough people recommending you and then
the fourth thing is being what I call
industry savvy that means being a
student of the business so you know
what's going on you know who the players
are if you're lucky enough to get a
meeting then you don't put your foot in
your mouth by saying great television
series that had been cancelled you know
like six months ago it's all of those
four things combined when I look at
successful people and I've done studies
of them so that I can share that with
people
that's where I've come up with those
four sort of pillars of blazing hot
material a smart self marketing plan
enough contacts and industry savvy
you